hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is
are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're going to be
classy
or they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful spring day
we're down here at antoni's basement uh
the patreon has gone straight to her
head yeah
we have a little bit of a situation i
can't wait i'm just gonna tell you
okay now that you've opened these doors
okay
people are gonna expect to have a
certain lifestyle moving forward i gotta
i gotta pay for her month to month you
gotta pay for her all right all right
because
i've been paying for you month-to-month
this whole time i got a little bit more
news for you
what she walked out of the acting she
all she saw you quit your day job
so she wants to quit her day job now
okay so we really got
buy a couple of tickets to see us in
indy chicago hit the patreon
no money mo problems yeah buddy you're
telling me
she's got this lackey that she's
bringing around this guy donnie
she's he's gonna need to be on the take
too we gotta we gotta find a broom for
him to push around all right how long is
this
buddy i give you leeway to write your
own hoodie bits
come on gang that is my co-host that you
hear my boss really
yeah all right partners this guy saved
me in 51.49
i'm like i'm like [ __ ] portnoy over
here baby i want it
all dang give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey what's up gang thanks for
tuning in
as always please make sure you rate you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are
true the roof yes true to [ __ ] roof
and then patreon.com
i gotta say i thought youtube was
cooking patreon is [ __ ] cooking baby
uh head over there you get bonus
episodes at ayg
you get episodes of hard feelings which
is uh just me and foley behind the
curtain a little bit mixing it up
[ __ ] on each other i call him fat he
calls me bald it's a good [ __ ] time
and then every month we do a live stream
with our top two tiers where you ask us
questions we ask you questions
get involved come on and hang out with
us gang we love you
and we also love our producer
extraordinaire who i would like to give
a quick shout out to you
if i may give it up for our good pal the
pride of the chicago comedy scene
he's wearing a shrimp daddy t-shirt give
it up
for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen t-bone
what a boy
what's up happy to have you back bro you
look at me with such disdain
every time i think about what i'm
looking at he's not a fan no i'm just
it's nine times out of ten i'm getting a
shot my voice cracked like a 14 year old
i'm obviously i've been out of the game
for one week i got [ __ ] no skills i
got no chops
like i feel like i feel like i'm under
the guns kfc's looking to make up the
[ __ ] store
instagram it's like staring at the
barrel of [ __ ] nine million views
daily
and i gotta [ __ ] be funny right off
the cuff come on let me warm up let me
put the [ __ ] donut on the bat
this kid playing it cool huh all right
take a walk catch a bernie or something
eat your heart out paul newman
this kid's ice cold it's good to be back
you just refer to paul newman
i love paul newman anyway listen gang
this is a [ __ ] family episode
we got a little company in the building
as t-bone said
we got a little [ __ ] star power here
yeah okay if you have not seen this
episode
go back and check it out it's absolutely
amazing he's a bit of an enigma
why become and explain it first i want
to let everybody know that
he's one of the stars of barstool sports
he's the host of kfc radio
he's the host of the kevin clancy show
and he's the brains behind and the host
of one minute man videos which are
absolutely [ __ ] fantastic
he breaks something down in one minute
they're amazing and he's got a brand new
project coming out called 10 topics
in 10 minutes it's a new series it's
gonna be more of that it's absolutely
fantastic
you would think he's a classy guy
tight body good looking kid yes as well
good hair compared to him you got a
tight body you got to tell you you're
very humble about that
and he's walking in his own merch which
is fanta you look like a lululemon
coming but that shows that he's trash
he's hawking his merch on our show but
it's good stuff
you know what no you know what it it's
it's not even that it i g and i it is
trash
because i just only wear my own [ __ ] now
yeah like
it's like samples and maybe some sponsor
clothes
i have not [ __ ] bought uh clothes and
i don't think i ever will again
but also you eat oreos with a fork
classy gobs no you eat gobs of peanut
butter
out of the container see no problems
what's the problem and you decorate your
christmas tree with mets blanket it's a
build it's just a blanket well i didn't
decorate the tree instead of doing a
tree skirt i did a met's blanket
you had a mets hoodie on top of your
tree
what i did have is a a piece
of my blinds sure rammed up the back of
the tree to make it stay up
right and also he only decorated the
front of the train true pointed that
great in the back nobody sees it
you showed us well i show it to you you
know so that's what i mean when i say
your enigma ladies and gentlemen give it
up for mr
kevin clayton i'm part of that part of
the credits there you gotta put that i'm
a card-carrying patreon member he is
true ten dollars
oh really yeah they're calling you sir
i'm your boss too yeah he can cut the
lights at any minute if he wants
i always like to hear from the board any
suggestions
every shareholder gets to say it that's
right are you garbage incorporated
you're not buying a company folks you're
buying a family
a big old trashy family oh yeah family
episode
here we are we're doing we're doing some
cubes family episode
family i'm watching that show on hbo
mayor of east town
i can't i tried i can't get behind it uh
it should put the accident the accident
is tough
are they are they good or bad like from
your point of view is that like the
first
the first time she tried to drop it she
was in the kitchen at that old broads
house and she said like
downtown it was too hot it was too bad
you're critiquing
kate winslet's acting is that what's
happening right now true you might we
might not have walked out
jacket
i'm not i'm not saying she's a bad
actress girl's got chops i'm just saying
kate winslet i'm just saying it's the
litter and the home
and the family she hit some of some of
them yeah i can't believe they made a tv
show about coatesville that that blows
my [ __ ] mind
i think it's pretty good but but the
accents i heard i heard a lot of like uh
philly friends of mine being like do i
do i really talk this is what i sound
like i
talk yeah you do you [ __ ] trash you
do it's tough
you don't realize my mom sounds at my
nieces and nephews
hey get me a hater i'm like i'm going
back to new york i'll see you it's it's
like divine intervention that you guys
call it a hoagie and have that accent
oh hey give me a huge
yeah dude it's a [ __ ] real real tough
life i also want to say shout out you've
been a big supporter of us from the
beginning
i got recognized at the airport and i
was like yo hey he came up he's like i
take a visual how'd
some people initially heard of it but i
wax poetic every time i talk about you
guys you say it in the intro it's
everybody's new favorite favorite new
podcast and it really is i mean he's so
humble isn't it
yeah he's too humble it's hard to make i
i
should be flexing on people i've been
saying i got nothing to flex i'm skinny
fat you see you keep you keep saying
that you you're a good looking
you're like a movie star good looking
from the knockout take it down
he's not moving i mean i like him he
ain't movie star good looking
i think he could pull it off what do you
mean maybe an indie
maybe a horror well what did uh i think
distefano it might have been
chrissy d might have said uh he said
this about feidelberg or someone said it
about chris
oh yeah yeah
i am telling people now when new people
come to bar stool or just new
personalities whatever
they're talking about making content and
for the most part i usually tell them
don't make a podcast
because i think it's kind of too late i
think it's over saturated
yeah uh and i would say that you know
but you guys kind of like
defy that i mean you guys came in in a
point where every comic already has a
show and everybody's got a podcast and
everybody's got their rotation
and you guys cracked in in a major way
and like and are growing faster than
anyone anyone else i would tell them
kind of do like one minute man make an
instagram account make a social media
trying to do quick blah blah
because the idea of like another
one-hour show podcast about comedy or
whatever yeah yeah but
but but you guys got the goods and you
got a great hook for it so uh
defying the the trends if you will it's
amazing i've been toying with
with going influencer i've been thinking
about it
i am i'm currently only with the
t-scrubs on his face
i'm putting a team together right now
i'm trying to get a flight to ibiza
oh yeah that's what it's called
you gotta hit the th oh really now does
delta fly there
will frontier go there what's going on
can i get a south west
we've got to get foley on yacht week you
guys ever see yacht week no what is it i
want to go
in like 2009 this was when we first
started i know our next patreon goal
shut up the [ __ ] oh my god if you guys
dude that's it we got a little bit of
cash
is it actually oh so this is what
happened we're gonna run a crabbing boat
i got a bunch of hand lines out with
bunker on the end can we rent one of
those boats from deadliest catch
or something like that i got the
cornelia marie we got the big [ __ ]
take her down to florida oh now we're
talking right yeah
guys the patreon is canceled fully get
crushed by crap
[Laughter]
fully stuck in a crab pot don't you low
in that thing
don't you do it i wouldn't last 10
minutes on that deck
dude those guys ripped the hardest
bernies on that [ __ ] show too oh they
got the big rubber gloves i'm like
you're getting the city
what's going on here outside in the
middle of the north arctic
trying to [ __ ] rip a marble light
that's
tough buddy those dude they're not marv
like kind of guys those are either full
flavor or menthol dudes yeah they're
definitely hundreds
this new menthol band's gonna be tough
for those guys they're like what what's
going on
in menthol they're bannon mental
cigarettes
saying that it's like they're saying
it's like a flavor yeah right right what
are people gonna do for their cough
that's what i do when i'm not feeling
well i get a newbie
open her up a little bit get a couple of
ports but hold on all right go back to
what's yeah so yeah
this was probably like 2009 or 10. i
first got like
uh no no no no no [ __ ] [ __ ] right right
denied me you talk about the dating app
right now really put me on the wait list
oh you bozo yeah yeah apparently you're
in here talking you up you're telling us
no i can't even get on [ __ ] raya
um so listen so all of a sudden this
video came out it was like yacht week is
like this it's like a company
and they put out like a trailer uh-huh
try to find like go to youtube
this is yacht week yeah go to go to
youtube though and like find like
there's like one video that's probably
like it's kind of it's probably like
what like what they try to do with uh
what was the island fire festival yes
where they all was like this
is all your wildest dreams so in this
video though it had like the new
techno song that was out at the moment
edm playing beautiful girls
you know drone shots and all of us we
all kind of found it at the same time
this all sounds like me and it was i
mean we were like
this is the greatest thing i've ever
seen of course you know what are you
going there what is it and so you
it's it's rather expensive but i think
you basically you have to get like a
crew together
like 10 or 12 people whatever like this
boat fits and you rent the boat
you get a boat like a sailboat and i
think you can do it where like you can
sail yourself
or you if you need a crew you have to
pay for that uh and you go
either to ibiza or the mediterranean and
croatia there's a couple different spots
you can do it
and you're with like a fleet of other
yeah you probably go like boat to boat
yeah you're banging hookers and i i
think
in practice it becomes a little bit of
like a sausage fest where it's a bunch
of guys being like
we're gonna go you know the video has
girls making out with chicks and they're
all beautiful i think you go and it's
kind of like a spring break thing where
it's like
well all the dudes came here looking for
one thing the girls didn't show up yeah
yeah yeah
but somebody's mom's there yeah i know
jimmy can't go without a chaperone
you guys did casey casey smith went on
yacht week um when she first
came to barstool she got she earned the
nickname of bisa casey because
because like at barstool we don't really
do vacations like portnoy's one of those
guys like you can take a vacation if you
want i didn't for the first 10 years but
okay you can
you know so like that's a lot of time
i'm gonna start throwing that around
i told him he doesn't get any sick days
either we didn't take one for the first
11.
yeah i still haven't taken a vacation
yeah so but she missed like the first
her like first week was like that's okay
and i yeah i'll be back in like two
weeks
and yeah week but she said it was
amazing but yeah if you guys get that
sounds pretty classy uh you know 10 000
this whatever and you guys go on yacht
week holy [ __ ] what kind of numbers are
we talking
i don't think i know 10 people yeah
that's i don't i don't quite know
exactly i've never looked into the
logistics
i think it's actually not that bad i
mean there's a there's definitely a
[ __ ] low hanging we're gonna need can
i bring
can i bring my old can i bring my old
man is the yacht uh parkinson's uh
accessible maybe captain yeah he's he'll
be a skipper
we're not having him in charge of the
boat get the big guy in the back with a
couple of yinglings i
saw a couple of bridesmaids guys they
would they would be like
they'd be like their money's like taking
money back we gotta do this we gotta do
something on a boat though that's the
next thing because
also so we just hit the we just had to
go full on patreon foley's not
foe's never been in a limo right ever
right no so now we're going we're going
out to the one there's a mcdonald's on
long island in the mansion i don't know
if you know that of course we're gonna
i don't know if this might be news to
t-bone too we're taking that we're all
getting dressed up in suits
and we're going out to [ __ ] the
mansion the mcdonald's mansion
can i be the limo driver we're getting a
hat on and everything that's pretty can
i be your driver
i'll have a cheese pizza waiting for you
like kevin mcallister i like it
yeah you know you know how to get to
volley do you currently have your tlc
license
yeah um [ __ ] that's great yeah we're
gonna get a couple ladies of the evening
too
um i want like some old hookers yeah
like some real
disgusting yeah we're gonna spend more
money on the suits
yeah we could bring our hobbies what we
could bring our moms get them all dolled
up
jesus christ he's like we're gonna bring
some old [ __ ] like how about our moms
[ __ ] that was a little too quick yeah
well my mom's open that day i think like
a family price have we hit this or is
this the next goal uh we hit it
okay so this is done at the planet we
have that and then we also have to do
the uh the honeymoon getaway which we'll
pull the poconos and the martini glasses
and the heart-shaped uh yeah okay which
i don't want to when they're
[ __ ] disgusting trash i once went to
i want pokemons
and the only thing i remember there was
those like heart shape it was a family
reunion type we don't do that but there
was like one time where we met with like
and you meet the other cousins dude
and we only ever did it once yeah we
don't we're i'm a very
like even my aunts and uncles like it's
just me my mom and dad and sister
brother like
very tight that's it but we went and the
only thing i remember
was is there like a caesars in the
poconos yeah yeah there was
right yeah yeah i don't know if it's
still there but there was jesus i
remember a roller skating rink and i was
like this is
at the time i was like this is cool
looking back i was like we are
deplorable
we are disgusting family what are we
doing if you're not even at the caesars
in atlantic city right it's a tough look
which is trash to begin with but if
you're like wow it's only it's 50 bucks
cheap in the poconos
the atlantic city man i i feel like uh i
went to a bachelor party a couple years
ago at atlantic city
i feel like if you go to atlantic city
now you have to do it embracing the
garbage
of course by the way june 18th atlantic
city live show there you go
there you go here we go over there at
the celebrity theater come
see us get some decks i you know i feel
like if you go and you're like okay
we're gonna go to uh i think it's bear
exposure where you can like bring the
three
rocks you roll in with the beers yes
yeah yeah but like we went on a bachelor
party where it was like okay
first night yeah bear exposure i think
it's called that and it's like it's byob
and it's like it's a real [ __ ] real
dirtbag hole in the wall there's like
one rule no penetration and that's even
you know getting real
handsy in ac but but you know if you go
one rule no kissing
don't look her in the eyes either turn
your right to stone
if you go being like you know we were
like we're gonna do a nice dinner the
first night and then we're gonna go to
the club the next science because we're
in atlantic city yeah none of this is
nice
no you gotta embrace the guard you're
all lying to yourself right at that
point
i figured you know we could you know get
up early and we'll hit you shut the [ __ ]
up yeah
that plays like a car mines or something
like that or you do the bigger thing
for the home style or family style come
heavy don't be like a couple bumper
gummers
wandering around the casino one o'clock
in the morning see if anybody can
straighten this out
you come ready for those kind of things
make sure i'm packing they don't come at
all
in all pms take the edge off
good all right yeah let's get into some
[ __ ] questions baby we've got a
family
up here we got some heaters um speaking
of casinos this is pretty good guys so
as you know when you join the patreon we
will answer your garbage question
on the air best way to do it um this is
from
max r uh have you or anyone in your
family ever taken an infant zero to
three years old to las vegas
no because my family i mean you have
yeah yeah yeah my brother my little
brother went
where my dad got married you said what's
the age limit zero to three
you go to las vegas if you are the only
way you should be a three-year-old in
las vegas is if somehow you were born in
las vegas
exactly yes
or you're being trafficked yeah i mean
that is some garbagio
and just like who who wants to do that i
mean that means that
at times you're just leaving your kid
alone he's wandering the short floor of
the casino
yeah yeah yeah yeah or you got your
other big-headed kid watching the
kid in the hotel room while you're down
at the [ __ ] craps if i if i
ever do kids in vegas you know what i'm
doing i'm thinking about making this
this switch in general
oh i like this yeah americans don't do
it too much
i think we should the kids on a leash oh
what that's a tough look dude no way
it's so convenient
what i also i don't have kids so i don't
know but your kids are too old to be
are they running away they're in like a
chest you know it's like around their
neck it's like
yeah they're not a [ __ ] doctor a
little like a bungee cord but
man it would be nice to just be like i'm
at the table honey all right
she's wrapped up
you're not but you're allowed to they're
allowed to be like i remember what the
[ __ ] is there for a kid to do in vegas
like
circus circus there's a lot of those
shows circus circus is a
casino for kids or not a casino is a
hotel casino for kids
at the [ __ ] ball right up step right
in one starburst wins every prize
i'll see you two fruit snacks
the least thing is but rather uh rather
um
it's just practical he's got these
[ __ ] kids running around there's you
could run out in the street you could
get kidnapped you could get this i could
just yank you
i remember josh wolf telling me a story
when he was a single dad you know his
whole background
he was raising these kids all on his own
sure i could imagine he told me he used
to put these kids on leashes
where it was almost like hannibal lecter
where like they could run right up to
the stove but not
so they would like run for the like i
want to play with fire and then
it's like a dog running at you and he
had it so that they couldn't get they
couldn't reach each other so they would
be
like they'd run at each other and try to
attack and they couldn't reach it like
fighting
[ __ ] betta fish you put that one in a
separate tank
she bit the other ones clean off once
you're outnumbered with kids i mean i've
always heard people say like
you know you have your first kid and you
can you as parents you can double team
them
and then you have two kids and you play
man-to-man and then when you got to
switch to zone defense when they
outnumber
oh wow that's a good way to show you
know so i'm just going to chain them all
up
i'm going to keep them right in my
[ __ ] i'm going to yank you around
or or perhaps not go to las vegas yeah
hang on there partners let's talk real
real quick here
all right about our new sponsor bespoke
post spring's coming getting back
outdoors
summer's coming bespoke post has all
your adventure
all your top of the line needs okay with
their box
of awesome you got to get it brand new
box of awesome collection for guys
guaranteed to upgrade your life all
right and this is whether you like going
out and tame in the wilderness being an
outdoor guy
or you're trying to take your home bar
to [ __ ] pro
levels yeah bespoke post only sends guys
the best stuff every single month no
matter what you're into the box of
awesome as you're covered
from style grooming goods you got bar
wear you got cooking tools you got
outdoor gear their box of awesome has
collections
for everybody in every part of your life
yeah they sent us a box of [ __ ]
big old boxes [ __ ] i got it me and my
wife opened up like it was [ __ ]
christmas morning baby
uh they sent us a knife with a [ __ ]
cool case i feel like i'm [ __ ]
crocodile dundee i'm building a cabin
with it
we got a knife we got a duffel bag that
i'm taking out on the road because i
needed a new duffy it could be called
dibs on the duffel
nice stuff called dibs on the duff nice
stuff it's got like a metal ring it's
like we said before it's cool guys [ __ ]
you're getting a bunch of cool guy if
you're not a cool guy you're trying to
be a cool guy
they make you a [ __ ] cool guy yeah
it's not like i got the short under the
stick either i got the hammock
and i got the tent yes so to get started
take a quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box
they want to know what you're into for
you though new boxes every month
tons of different categories it's free
to sign up you can skip a month cancel
at any time and
you want to you want to hear the kicker
this is not each box only costs 45 bucks
but has over 70
worth of gear inside cool guy [ __ ]
you hear that t-bone that's what we're
talking about get 20
off your first box uh your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter our promo code
garbage
check out that's box of awesome.com use
promo code garbage
for 20 off your first box do it
today hey gang want to talk to you about
our new sponsor lucy nicotine
lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine
alternative couple of brainiacs on the
case finally
a tobacco alternative that doesn't suck
yeah all right this guy spent three
years researching
okay creating the product for people not
patients
they cared about the human being lucy
has created a nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine
that comes in three amazing flavors you
got wintergreen
you got cinnamon oh yeah if you want to
go a little fruity what do you got
pomegranate what are you going to do
what are you going to do pomegranate
don't even stop there maybe if you don't
like the gummy like a lozenge you get a
four milligram lozenges of nicotine
cherry ice flavor cherry ice old school
baby back to the street
each flavor is great tastes awesome it's
convenient to scrape products it can be
enjoyed anywhere on flights on work
on the go gym whatever you want to do
you know what you think no one's got to
know
they sent us some and i got to tell you
i've been trying to you know i've been
on the bernie's been off the bernie's
been trying to kick him back on them
back in
everything it definitely helps give it a
try
uh definitely helps with the urges
everything like that it's i mean
you can't be smoking bernie's forever
you got to do something here give it a
whirl and i know a lot of our listeners
smoke them
guys it's 20 21. you got to get rid of
your cigs unplug the vape throw out the
dip and get some lucy nicotine gum or
lozenges it's the real deal a
subscription to lucy
comes directly to your door each month
it's simple easy you don't have to leave
your house lucy comes
straight to the source are you garbage
listeners go to lucy.co and use promo
code garbage to get
20 percent 20 off all products on your
first order including gum or lozenges
that's lucy dot co use promo code
garbage at checkout
also guys i have to tell you give the
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine derived from
tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical but you probably
know that get off the bernie's go to
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code garbage baby
now back to the show that's
you you so you uh we're trying no
i was 10 i was 11 my dad was getting
remarried
that was the 90s though you could have
got jacked and they'd
nobody there was
wow yeah like he was like maybe two and
so that's crazy i think it's a little
nice to even bring you how old are you
it's nuts for my dad to get my dad to
get married in vegas they were getting
married we were all in the wedding which
was enough i forget whose question but
if you've ever been in your parents
wedding that's a tough [ __ ]
look being like a [ __ ] 37 year old uh
ring bear or whatever
lil kipi and elvis yeah i'm strutting up
the hall i'm strutting up the aisle
get up there and do jailhouse rocks
don't [ __ ] up your lines this time
either vegas is tough you should only go
to vegas with your bull
like a [ __ ] party or gamble or
whatever like
families in vegas shouldn't be happening
no but
hey i am what happened that's a good one
to keep in the [ __ ] rolodex there of
cards
i can't remember where i saw this it was
either the facebook group or it was uh
uh patreon or something but somebody was
talking about watching your parents
drink with strangers like when you're a
kid that's really
what ends up happening in those with
like strangers that you don't know where
they don't know that they don't
talk like them hanging out with people
at the bar where you're like you're like
you're at the bar too
you know i was a bartender yeah i was a
market oh i would always sneak up to the
bar
yeah a couple of [ __ ] maraschino
cherries yeah but
it was always for me it was always that
like uh um like we had this little
it's called like the yacht club on city
island in the bronx it's just like where
people put their [ __ ] boats sure
but we were not on yacht week i know
that no for sure
but but i was never just like you know
mom and dad were at like the [ __ ] pub
and i it was like you know we were
we were there you were there
and so you see them milling around with
some characters but i think when you're
like
let's go to the bar and pack the kids up
yeah that's that's that's
you're crossing a line there to another
you know some people do it some people
don't but it is definitely a different
thing
than seeing you know at the at the
bennigan's you know seeing mom and dad
at the ground round
yeah shout out to the ground realm
remember that oh i missed those that's
come up a couple of times
is there is there those are gone those i
think there might be some in the south
we found out okay so it's still
alive is there is there like i remember
outside that was where you paid your
weight or something right it was like a
penny a pound
they ran it for a minute until the
foley's rolled up i've had to
i've had to make that same joke i for
sure have made that [ __ ] through that
you've covered the ground i've gotten
i have three jokes and they're all about
foley's weight or his family
the the the bennigan's ground round
there was one it was a place called
steak and ale
uh and i because i lived outside for a
long time
they're all the same company and for a
while they were all [ __ ] fantastic
what's next what's now though
because they do like the [ __ ] well
it's a little more rough grill
yeah it's like it's like they've gotten
better at making cat
nicer stuff casual right like bonefish
girl cheesecake factory that type of
[ __ ]
these kids growing up in this generation
no yeah if you're never gonna know the
ground round life
if you're gonna if you're gonna look
back and be like oh remember when the
family went to cheesecake factory it's
like
yeah oh there was another houlihan's
with the [ __ ] checkered tables
shout out to hula hey the guys smoking
next to you drinking out of those
pilsner glasses
yeah i'm telling you what you're living
that's clean
there uh what's this hitting on your mom
whatever
mommy why are you talking to that man um
shut up another big one was fuddrucker
do you remember fuddrucker
[ __ ] that i know that this is what he's
talking about that's when you started to
cross the line with [ __ ] fuddruckers
when all of a sudden it became a [ __ ]
broadway show i hate that
i want some joint at lunchtime where i'm
eating with my aunt
where there's [ __ ] some guy that just
lost his job at the bar
nursing a [ __ ] cuddy sark [ __ ]
chop caesar salads going around stuffed
mushrooms
mozzarella sticks and the [ __ ]
shirley teas are on point
that's what i want pablo picasso yeah
right his masterpiece right here
i don't want the [ __ ] hard rack cafe
or whatever wait wait what about
like the chains the the applebee's the
uh chili's the
thing we talk about a lot so it's like i
i think we've talked i think the pretty
much
than any of them yeah for sure i think i
might have told this or not i don't know
i'm banned from applebee's
like in the north america or i don't
know exactly how much
applebee's there was one applebee's that
banned me and the way they described it
was like your band for life
yeah something tells me their cyber
security probably
you know it's like getting banned from a
stadium it's like there's no way you can
enforce this but we went to an
applebee's we were doing the toboggan
championship in maine
in boss for barstool we went out and
filmed the video where we tried to
toboggan to the championship
and there was a applebee's and
we were there all day uh-huh and they
have a rule that's like you can only
have like six drinks totally i do i do
remember but i was like lady we've been
here for like eight hours
so it's like i'm not we're not
shit-faced whatever they're like sorry
so we left and we just like changed our
shirts and came back when they were like
now you're banned for life because
you're like now you're trying to [ __ ]
with that they were like we got the eye
of this guy
that was something he doesn't even work
there anymore
but those don't the chain doesn't have
the same effect either i feel like you
know
there's one in new england called the 19
um the 99 or something like that
there's a couple i've seen those 99 it's
like a horseshoe or something maybe yeah
that's they're all regional but those
places are money
um what else we got yeah let's see wait
wait real quick before we move on
fuddruckers just says hot dogs what
about that is a broadway
show i don't know the name all the stuff
in there
affection i thought you thought that
they were singing like in cold stone or
something yeah i did get that vibe too
that they put on a performance for you
you just meant that the hot dogs is too
much of bells and whistles huh he's so
opinionated on things that he has no
idea i've never actually been there
yes of course dude that is that is the
epitome of
the show but we never went to places
like that so [ __ ] up yeah see
this is it whenever fuddruckers came up
more we're not going there yeah
i took because i was like i know the
name phone ruggers but i've never been
there i'll take your word for it yeah
this man sounds like he knows now i'm
also
they're great yeah i'm sure it's a
fantastic it's no hooligans i can tell
you that
you guys see that sonic you eating that
sonic yeah we were just talking about
this i think last week it [ __ ] stinks
everything misses there's only one
nearby here right like jersey i think
there's
one there's probably one in jersey we
always see the commercials and i'm like
everybody [ __ ] that's everybody but
we can't even go there who's [ __ ]
where are they getting this advertising
money for him that you're advertising in
markets that you don't even have a
[ __ ] location tv ain't what it used
to be
and then one no this one this was in the
90s i know you guys are just
we're flaming this place right now but
you two should be the new sonic guys
those guys he hates those every time i
know wouldn't you love to replace them
wishing one of them would blow each
other's head off
why are two grown men in a car than a
[ __ ] business week having lunch
shouldn't they be at the office
what's going on we literally just did
that on monday i was going to say
her before you before that car
i don't know just in general before we
go down the road of you
criticizing the behavior of two grown
men yeah just
you know welcome to our garbage
literally in a glass house right now so
let's be careful who has a milkshake on
a wednesday yeah
i do their milkshakes are good fun
ruckers no
okay next one this this this might be
kfc have you ever
this is from athena have you ever worn
sweatpants on a date
brother i'm wearing i wore sweatpants to
work today those aren't sweatpants
buddy those are those are sweatpants no
they're not they're not i do know what
he's saying
so right now he's not wearing [ __ ] a
pair of russell's yeah
yeah but those are that's not a date
have you ever worn something on a date
that you shouldn't have worn on a date
yeah i mean that definitely works
if you met her at five o'clock on a
saturday for a drink i could see you
popping in with that
yeah no way yeah down at cooper's not a
[ __ ] uh
in these fellas no no that's insane i
would not do that
i would do like um i guess it depends on
your definition of date if i've ever
been like let's go
out to for drinks or dinner i'd probably
put a slack on i probably should
shot gentlemen really yeah all slacks
now i got a little bit of cash
i was thinking about it i was looking up
slacks the other day
yeah man are we talking like like the
the the the um the crease down the
middle
at the bottom oh yeah i want to get
really into nice shoes too
like ferragamo type shoes i don't know
just whatever i don't know
i want to start dressing like de niro
and the irishman i'll be honest with you
nice short sleeve shoes
the new money trash that's going to come
from oh i get this
it's already happening you know these
guys get a little
bit of skrilla next thing you know
they're wearing slacks and
ferragamos i'm deep into cryptocurrency
too
i just bought two sauna blankets
i've done uh uh like pair of sweatpants
what i i
i love the wave that we're on right now
this like athleisure wear wait
that's what i'm making here i mean i got
these lounge pants i got these
sweatshirts where it's like
you could wear it to the gym like i'm
not going the [ __ ] gym you could wear
it to work you could wear it to the bar
you could wear it out i'm like then
okay i'm gonna take if that's what
that's what they're doing loud i'm gonna
take you away
you wear that out would you if your
buddies were like hey we're meeting up
for drinks around like six five or six
yes you wear that so like that's what i
was gonna say i probably have met a girl
at a bar on the weekend like a sunday
fun day like meet me at the bar so is
that a date
probably not but i definitely have gone
but you're trying to impress her yes i
have been in a situation
where i'm meeting a girl that i am
interested in that i'm trying to impress
that i've worn yes sweatpants for sure
sorry my kickball game just ended
the red team won that these zog sports
[ __ ]
show yeah i did the whatever dude
i could see you getting so fired up
about like a three-legged race
at like a family event with your kids
like fighting another dad
come on run get up no i i i am important
like flag football
what's going on still got your flags on
oh [ __ ] i forgot my flags
i i've been taking it i take my son to
soccer
on saturdays these days and so i'm
getting my first taste of like other
dads and
kids and [ __ ] and so like he's he's
three
we're not playing soccer we're just
[ __ ] around yeah running around yeah
but there's some kids wearing like
you know shin guards and cleats and
wearing like a paper
vapers on or whatever yeah find out how
really [ __ ] [ __ ] up people are
yeah right these dads and moms and
children i don't want to be that
i could never be that like earl woods
type of dad i'm like you're just going
to be average
you know oh yeah like i was thinking
maybe by you know by now tiger was
[ __ ] on the fairway you know and i'm
like at the driving range
i'm like i'm like but that's right i was
on the tonight show at two
that's what i mean it's like your kid
has more credits than you might [ __ ]
do
if you want you know if you want to like
have your kid be like great in life you
gotta like start
doing that [ __ ] at this age i'm like i
just don't want to do it yeah like he
could he could be showing
like that
so you're not you know he could be
showing me signs of like brilliant
[ __ ] talents and i'd be like well i
don't know yeah we're just going to have
a birthday and get him a thermos and
some work gloves
[Laughter]
i got you an apprenticeship in the
electrical union they got good
pennies now give me my sweatpants i
gotta go to work
[Laughter]
this next one's just hilarious he ain't
gonna make it this is he's
two yeah this is from david smith how
much driving you doing with your knee
the way they ask the questions are so
good
here's the thing when you're driving
with your knee that seats back way too
far than it should be
your seats are climbed too fast but
older cars my my loom shout out to the
[ __ ] chevy loom rest in peace
big knee cause you were like man i was
my left knee i can i can i'll drive
anywhere any place like i'm spinning the
whole wheel
that's [ __ ] garbage i mean i'm so
trash and i'm i'm like i'm texting i'm
tweeting i'm putting up one minute man i
mean
i i i edited a video the other day while
i'm driving oh i'm like
no i don't have a test a hyundai tucson
uh that's fully operated by the human
and i'm sitting there i mean you know
it's it's i'm a big time knee driver
that's a touch i didn't think that was
garbage [ __ ]
oh that's true that's what you know it's
funny when like ultimate learning
the ultimate garbage epiphanies is when
you didn't even know things were garbage
sure i'm like
yeah i do that and you start then you
reverse engineered a little bit you're
like oh [ __ ] that
i would have been like [ __ ] yeah driving
my knee that's cool and everyone else is
like that makes you a loser
yeah yeah yeah yeah the that the leg up
when people like
girls do this a lot they have like a
little like a leg up i would do that my
leg would be to the left
my foot would be to the left of the
steering wheel like so it would be like
here
so so i do yeah i'm garbage it was a 96
chevy aluminum with the paint
how far do you put your leg up when you
put your leg on i would put my leg on
the dashboard no that's crazy
yeah that's crazy i'm the limited man
people do that on the passenger side too
that's garbage my wife does it i'm like
get your [ __ ]
first of all i got that brand new kia by
the way shout out to the good folks over
there north star auto group
i'm like get your [ __ ] feet off my
dashboard is down
i put my foot on on the door there's
like a little like slanted uh
you know on the door you have like a
little yeah thing to put your stuff in
yeah
put your foot in there and i don't put
it on i put it on it but there's like uh
when you see those people like you're
driving normal and you see a dog hanging
out the window like
toes flapping in the wind that's a tough
[Laughter]
uh this next one's from diamond i we've
touched about this
diamond diamond where can i see you
dance coming
uh is it garbage to bathe with just a
bar of soap to the skin and no washcloth
that's that's well no please i was gonna
say as i've
i've learned in my internet travels
that's not as much of a class or
trash thing that is a ethnic thing
that's a big time white people thing
white people go straight bar yeah yeah
white people don't use uh
washcloths uh yeah and i am guilty of
that i never even considered it i think
it just adds to your laundry and
it's not necessary but what about the
scrunchies
yeah not that well you're trash if you
called it scrunchies no cause
a loofah is made of like is made of like
actual loofah whatever that is yeah the
the stuff that looks like ramen noodles
yeah okay okay yeah the scrunchies those
things you buy at cvs the little balls
is like a sponge it's no it's it well
it's it's kind of a luffa
treat yourself like a dirty pan yeah
[Laughter]
i think a deeper question is do you do
bar or body wash i'm irish spring all
day long oh wow that i mean you have not
graduated college you're still in your
dorm you know i just bought it
actually i just ran out i got blue or
the green you got to knock the lid off
i mean green if you're buying blue irish
spring get the [ __ ] out of my face oh
green irony no you gotta go blue
the blue yes oh the blue listen first of
all guy probably likes code red what is
it
no the blue is the classy within the
garbage world of irish spring sport the
blue is the
high school what is the blue it's called
something yeah you know it's probably
like cool
yeah yeah yeah definitely i uh
i used to love uh taking showers in a
girl's place
so you start dating a girl oyster blast
like moisture
i'm old school give me the tough stuff
put some [ __ ] hair in your chest
i want to see some cracks on this skin i
i used to love when you either start
dating a girl
or you're you're you're hooking up with
her enough consistently that you shower
at her place
you know i mean you walk into a girl's
shower nothing better the bells and
whistles it's like fuddruckers you got a
whole [ __ ] performance you got
you got the the scrunchies the losers
all the bars
smells like evidence girl she has this
this it looks like it looked like a
goddamn
sex toy you push a button and it spins
around oh yeah my girl's got that yeah
oh man i mean it's all it's it's that's
clean living i got on this uh and they
have these term you know the body butter
it's not even body wash it's like
yeah the butter spray and all these
things oh and then you can't go back to
your garbage spring sports just a girl's
bedroom like that is [ __ ] fantastic
the smells uh
appearances in this welcome to creepo
hour just even a girl's bedroom
sometimes they sniff her pillowcase this
is about garbage all right
not restraining orders i know what he's
talking about
my apartment's so garbage i just i've
like come to this realization recently
like when i so i got divorced and i was
kind of like
well you got an apartment because it
looks bit it's like a town it is big
it's like a two-family house type of
thing okay
two-family you know i've just seen it on
instagram yeah and it's like three
bedrooms
big but i like when i got divorced and
moved out and i like i was
i just was like i just need a [ __ ]
roof over my head like whatever and i
wanted to make sure the kids were all
set so everything was kind of going
to them and now it's been a little while
and i'm like got an upgrade
yeah it was just like i still have like
all the old furniture and the
like i never even cared about like okay
here's a good one where what's your bed
frame situation bed uh headboard
yeah frame all that stuff we have enough
for we got one
uh a couple of years ago i guess when we
moved in together
we got an affordable one from ikea it's
like
it's not gonna hit a headboard it's like
yeah it's like there's a headboard and
it's all together with like
legs what's yours you're a parent you're
making me real nervous
yeah i got like that you're even you
have the thing with the wheels the metal
frame with the wheels
i don't have wheels but you have a metal
frame you know and
yeah and it was like the one that like
bends and snap like no it's not quite
like that but
and then i have uh for the headboard is
like um metal boxes
metal it's like a little metal arc that
has like you know
it sounds midi i don't know i don't know
it's
i think it's black and then it's got
like a little like um it looks like like
crystal [ __ ]
on the top yeah but but it was like it
was the last thing i was worried about
in the moment
but now i'm like you know maybe it's
time to have a real [ __ ] i just don't
care about you the kids just started
asking questions yeah why does daddy
like where's daddy's place [ __ ] like
what's their homeless shelter what's
their rooms like are they hooked up are
they nice and yeah like that i mean
they have beautiful like one has a race
car bed she has like this
leather pull out bed thing that's
amazing like so they're all set and you
got the nice couch and the coffee table
and
the good tv right no
well the kids trash the kid here's the i
kept my mouth shut on the hyundai
listen now we're starting more than
hyundai money here's what happens if i
got killer money
brother you have at least board focusing
money driving like probably weren't you
driving like a like a cutlass or
a buick or something before no no no no
that wasn't you
no offshore did you just get a new car
because you're broke down
yeah uh so they they gave me like a
loaner in
while they were fixing it and it was the
whenever you're a loner it's always a
tough block
well no it's just like a courtesy car on
the back what's going on
[Music]
whatever the hyundai like the best
hyundai uh
suv is okay and it was my car was [ __ ]
so it was like a like a
month they had to order new parts and
have a chip and covered so i had this
like very nice as far as you got at
least baby you got it i know but i had
so i had this like a month
and then uh it came time to like give it
back and i just like wasn't answering
the phone for a few weeks that was kind
of like
you know they're like we're looking mr
clancy we're like we're looking for you
to return your this that so i had the
other one a few weeks
it was like two weeks yeah my dad did
that with enterprise rent-a-car dude
they came knocking one yeah
eventually eventually they were like we
ain't [ __ ] around no more
they got like my brother's number like
where the [ __ ] your dad with this
dodge neon he just liked it for some
reason
he had a nicer car yeah but he just like
zipping around a little goku wait a
minute sorry
how's this playing out so then in the uh
in the living room
i had a coffee table and wait did you
give the car back yeah i should get the
car back and so now you have
you got you're just back to my regular
home they fixed your car yes yes yes yes
but the living room situation i had this
big nice
remember there was that blip for a
minute where the curved tv was a thing
oh yeah so and like that's not a real
thing you know but i bought it it was i
had a good curve it was like 65 inches
it was curved
i went i i fell for that too when zoon
came out remember was zoon and ipods
yeah microsoft's ipod yeah i'm one of
like the nine people who have a zoom
that that is like my mom's like the guy
told me these are better i'm like oh
i'll buy one
that is like i got a zoom that's like in
the 80s being like i had better yeah
and then it just broke i don't know what
happened it just broke
and where's that tv now okay so he still
has it he still has it dude
bro i still haven't i was talking you up
in the beginning
i it's it's i still have it it's still
mounted
and the new tv is just beneath it
on the coffee table so i took the coffee
table from the middle so two things
happened my tv broke and also my kid
they were little and they're they
[ __ ] fell and hit their face on the
on the on the coffee table so i was like
i got to get the coffee table out of the
way of everything
so look the new tv is on top of the
coffee
you're living in a [ __ ] circuit city
[ __ ] going on
[ __ ] kevin foxworthy over here that's
what i'm saying so the other day i saw
like the bed
and i saw the tv and i was just like um
garbage you know i'm real garbage not
even you gotta get out of the way you
gotta get around
get on wayfair my brother get on with
that but it's just [ __ ] yourself
you know it's like who cares it's just
me and my kids you know like
they're probably look they're gonna
start looking around like what as soon
as my kids can judge me i'm gonna
bawling they're judging you dude i hate
to break it
four and three they're not judging me
they know they they know their mom
doesn't have nine tvs stacked on top of
each other and they go to [ __ ]
friends houses and [ __ ] like that
oh man they know they're coming back to
your
[Laughter]
they know what's going on man i knew i
was trash at a very early age
if they're judging me for that i want to
be getting credit for some of their
fancy [ __ ] at the at their mom's house
then
do i get some of that no no no it
doesn't seem like what are you doing
fancy [ __ ] no the brick exposed and the
nice
wood floors and the that's the tough
look you don't cause that man
they don't care that's the cross we bear
this thankless job yes
it really is so i'm just gonna sit here
with my shitty bed and my broken tvs
and be like as long as but then you're
gonna take it off and there's gonna be
the mounting bracket on there that's
gonna be a tough look it's a whole thing
with the mounting i couldn't put it up i
can't take it off
dude mountain tvs [ __ ] up walls
you even said that trash mountain tv i
first thought you meant like a mountain
tv
yeah i'm like does this guy get nobody
because nobody gets it right in the
first shot
you at least got three or four holes
back you guys handy at all no
we had to hang this we have a monitor in
there and we had to hang that
and i had my i was going to do it follow
he's like you want me to take over
knockout i'm like dude no way
we're not gonna get the [ __ ] security
deposit back if you try it
like could you could you uh can you
change a tire right now if you get a
flat i can change it i can do
i can do most of i can hang stuff in an
apartment but like i
if i was living by myself it would be
fine and yes but
the fact my wife goes like well this is
a little whatever that's whatever girl i
don't care about that but
so now we just i just pay someone to
come in and take always i mean
my thing in life is always like i just
want to be uh
well off enough that i can just pay
people to do the [ __ ] i can't do well
here's the thing that's a lot of things
they do it better i know me they do it
better and they do it quickly and so
if you're talking about putting up a big
tv into a wall like if i do this i'll
probably
cobble it together and then one day i'm
going to close the door and then yeah
yeah i'm one of those people that i
prefer like i i like when somebody else
makes me something to eat rather than i
make something to eat
or when somebody else thinks mom makes
it somebody else makes the bed you know
they do it better i don't know i don't
know but if but if i were to make it for
you
uh-huh you'd be like oh this tastes
better because someone else made it sure
yeah i made it for me it's the same
person making it i think this is
terrible right
it's right placebo effect yeah i don't
know about you per se
oh i make a great sandwich yeah [ __ ] you
foley
i'm gonna make you a sandwich i'm gonna
spit you got me nervous with the tv
yeah that's a tough look dude two tvs in
your living room well one that works
are you throwing down a nice lunch for
the kids you make a nice grilled cheese
or something like that i do a little
grilled cheese i make them like
whip up some hot dogs we do a lot of
pasta and chicken nuggets
okay that's what the kids the kids are
eating you know i'm not going to drink
pasta
[ __ ] swordfish or something jesus
[ __ ] you try the swordfish all right
what kind of sandwich
would i be looking at curiosity well you
tell me what you want i'm gonna make
what the big man wants you know
do you have selective cold cuts in the
house if if
if i knew i was making a sandwich for
you i would make sure i went and i got
almost everything to make you like a
little attacker's head yeah
though i got you know what i've seen
recently at the grocery store they have
a
little boar's head uh flyer whatever and
it says like you can get it thick you
can get it
this you can get a thin and then it goes
like shredded like they know they're
just
like i've seen it i don't know well i
like a little shredded roast beef and
make myself a cheesesteak
but i'm talk when i want my ham and my
baloney i wanna be able to like see
through it
oh yeah [ __ ] who gets it thick dude
that's garbage disgusting thick cold got
squirrels
put it on five yeah yeah sliced
in always oh always kid
and then you would get a piece of
american cheese while you're sitting in
a cart
good night cheese cheese is a garbage
thing for me that was a late in
life were you a craft singles so late in
life i learned like the difference
between the craft singles and and
how late is late like twenties wait
different
craft singles on one house like like a
slice of american cheese yeah i would
have always thought
we were a craft singles house through
and through they were so good
my brother's idea of a snack would be uh
two craft singles
a bag of chips and a pint of milk
that would be a snack for him that's
awesome that's fantastic
so we were eating a lot and like 12 more
craft singles
yeah we eat a lot more so we would do
grilled cheese we would put it on our
burgers
but sometimes we would just eat them
straight and i would acknowledge
obviously that there was a
like a texture difference but i was like
they taste the same and then and then i
started eating deli meat and i was like
oh no this is just better all the way
through the texture
the it doesn't stick to the plastic the
everything's better and yeah if i
if i go over your house and you make me
a sandwich a non-melted cheese
melted singles yeah if i can ask for
like a [ __ ] turkey and cheese and you
break out the craft singles i'm going to
[ __ ] burn your house down
if you hear that i'll be okay with that
of that like the rapper i'll be okay
with it
no i like them both i would be okay with
it i would not
you know i would not prefer it i i
wouldn't take it we're not eating lunch
and county dude yeah
yeah i mean if i ordered it from a deli
i'd be you know i i still wouldn't say
anything but
what about you you care about yellow or
white well
well yellow i'm usually yellow is a new
york thing oh
i didn't yellow american craft cheese
yellow american cheese is all
is a new york thing compared to philly
yeah oh yeah it's all white and filled
it's all white and filled like you go
get a bacon egg and cheese
slice of white cheese yeah yeah i mean i
don't really care myself but
orange you would get orange you would
get orange juice that like oh
you get a nice grilled cheese with
orange cheese on like a friday's or
something
yeah if i got a grilled cheese that was
white i'd be weirded out it's got to be
yellow man
yeah yeah you're making this up because
i know it's like a commercial
cheese it's gonna be yellow it's gonna
be white they love it it's all white
cheese don't tell
all white americans what the country
you're saying no no no no no no no
i'm just saying i didn't know actual
yell like you know it but
if you would go get a bacon egg and
cheese in philly
it was all white yeah we saw i only saw
yellow cheese if it was
if it was craft singles the stuff we got
from the grocery store
when we got our lunch meat for the week
yeah our ham our turkey or american
white for sammy's for school always
white yeah pound and a half of american
pound a ham pound of turkey beautiful
order you should slice them
then see through it yeah uh for a while
my dad gonna got on a cooper sharp kick
what's that that's some kind of white
cheese it was okay it wasn't great
what about a white cheddar that i was
going to say sharp is probably some sort
of cheddar
yeah scarves got to be a cheddar who the
[ __ ] eating white cheddar
shit's fire dude i don't know
like fire cheese and the little and the
little cracker barrel john's yeah
but not for sam you can just say john
yeah oh wow all right look at that yeah
look at that all right guys from the
streets yeah shout out to allegheny huh
[ __ ] guy john i'm gonna talk to the
corner man
all right next one this one's just
[ __ ] better we got to run through
some of these next one this is bananas
if you this is from romero uh did you
ever put already chewed gum in the
fridge to save it for later
i mean next question yeah this is
[ __ ] insanity that's crazy
don't don't you tell me you've done this
but you're all you're awfully quiet over
there big guy
come on get the [ __ ] out of here you've
done that dear mother
[ __ ] this is what i do no
this is the most genuine thing i've ever
seen both you're going ah this is what i
do
you dude you never speak my words
carefully because if i were him
and him i might break up with you with
what you're about to say here okay
i might never come on the show again if
you tell me that you put your dog in the
[ __ ] you're just gonna be back for the
sandwich
for later you're just mad at me for the
same holy [ __ ] what do you do tell me
okay
we just got a phrase we just got a
fridge you better tread carefully no
no no no no what i do is
okay let's okay so nervous let's say i
have a pack of
bubblicious or something like that you
know like an adult right
and i'm enjoying my gum i'm having a
piece i'm having another piece i'm
watching tv
i'll have a soda or something with me
you know i'll be drinking a soda or
whatever
okay what i'll do is the soda's nice and
cold right so when the gum starts to
lose a little bit of its flavor
i'll ball it up and i'll spit it into my
drink and let it go down to the bottom
and get hard
we checked toby you pull the plug on
this one and then when you put it back
in it's like a fresh piece of gum if you
don't believe me try it
which camera should i look at if you
don't believe me try
to put it into the soda into the sun you
got to finish your soda what's a piece
of common nickel
nickels you fish it out you fish it out
yeah and you enjoy the gum and the soda
together this man had the nerve
to judge me in my house a mere
five minutes ago yeah before unloading
that he puts his chewed gum in his soda
bottle
fishes it out i don't know and continues
i didn't even know i i was literally
going to say next question because
nobody does this and this [ __ ]
there's no way i'm come on when it does
that the only way that could have been
worse is if you could have if you had
started that sentence with your honor i
will represent myself
yeah and wait a minute you guys don't
spit your gum
into your drink if you're if you're at
if you're eating and then take it out
later piece of gum man the gum is gone
man you spit it out you swallow it you
get rid of it whatever
i always put my gum into my drink and
then finish it to me the gum goes in
first of all i think gum is just
first of all drinks ruin gum yeah you
can ruin gum if you if you're if you are
i'm not talking about a bloody mary i'm
talking about walking and drinking
something you you just do not have gum
at that point
yes your gums your gum expires that
madness you put gum in your mouth
the the gum goes in and then the gum
goes out and then that's it for that
that's it for that's that's it for that
piece of coffee onto the guard
like it's an asset not when you got a
hot pack of hubba bubba bro come on yeah
you got the pack of hubba bubba
that's even worse i only give you five
pieces yeah the the the cubes of gum is
tough you know it's
i can't believe i'm the only one that
you watch there's a lot of animals that
listen to this that probably for sure do
that back me up
now now i will say a step hold on wait
i'll wait put it in the fridge
yeah put it in the fridges but this is
even crazy what he's talking about he
puts in the fridge to
colt to cool it off to eat i put it i
put it in the freezer before just like
if i'm just goofing around
you know for shits and giggles you know
if i'm just like having me
if me and the wife are having a saturday
night this isn't recent this is like in
my 20s and 30s if i was like stoned or
something like that and i was chewing
gum
classic you never just chewed gums
ah you got me yeah you never just like
bought a couple packs of gum and chewed
gum while you were here
the inside of your apartment's like that
wall in seattle that's covered that's
covered in chewed gum
that wall freaks me out man that's just
gross gums gross you're gross
come on you know you know what i didn't
realize that that was gum on the streets
until like five years ago the spots all
those that's all gone
now it's that's actually one of the
funnier like quirky or fun facts in new
york it's
crazy it's just it's like targeted
stepped on
yeah so i mean i can't believe if
there's anybody out there that does that
kill yourself
where is straight up [ __ ] when was
the last time you swallowed a piece of
gum fully
i've done a dish i've done it i've done
it since this podcast has been on yeah
if i if i have a gum and then also
if i'm laying on the couch yeah and i i
got now i got no tissue or anything
i gotta get up and go to a garbage can
or something no i'm just swallowing that
that's so weird that you say that
because and i had probably hadn't done
it in
10 15 years i did it last night walking
to the stage because i had a piece of
gum
in my mouth a gentleman i've done like
an adult
but it does kind of sometimes you get
nervous i get nervous every single time
dude it's so ingrained in me from when i
was a kid every single time
if this is gonna kill me yeah yeah
that's how that it stays in your stomach
for seven years
yeah that was their legend we were told
seven years because it doesn't
it doesn't uh you know dissolve or
whatever i was petrified yeah as a kid
yeah that and uh insulation in the
ceiling i was like if you're going near
that you're [ __ ]
dead oh yeah answer immediately yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah shout out to
mesothelioma everybody
class action loss i know they hit you
with those commercials midday like in
between like what's happening in good
times
sometimes i'm like maybe i don't know um
jesus christ all right uh what was the
jesus christ given to this one
this one's from stevie b and i'm sure
it's happened a bunch
right have you ever there's so there's a
question and then holy explains it
have you ever watched your own birthing
video as in your parents filmed your
birth and you were alone at home one day
and found an
unmarked vhs only to watch your zero
birthday
enjoy dude if you're seeing your mom's
gash that is oh my god i'd rather see a
tape of them [ __ ] or something yeah i
would rather watch the conception than
the than the birth
hole the question should just be do your
parents have
have the birth tape because that's
garbage to watch it is not
garbage it's it's it's like insane it's
like you you're a sociopath yeah that's
crazy i mean you had an accident it's
like
what's this then you turn it off but you
know
any kid knows when you find an unmarked
vhs you're rolling the darts you're
about to see some [ __ ]
if it doesn't say happy gilmore billy
madison or blockbuster
yeah you're rolling the [ __ ] those
are the ones we actively looked for
oh landmarks yeah well of course yeah
you're hoping you strike
i'm looking for like undercover cops
baby unmarked vhs's all day
yeah playing club playing closed movies
we talk about this all the time
when you were when you were a kid did
you did you and your friends like
systematically go around at a certain
age
to everybody's house and like tear the
place apart looking for porn
yeah anything did you guys have the uh
like a box of
porn in the woods yes we never had a box
we had
found like a met you know you would find
it like piecemeal see because we like i
i have learned over my times at barcelo
that there are people who have the box
of porn in the woods
and there are people who have never
heard of this and they think that that's
garbage yeah and i'm like
that's just what it was we had like and
there was almost a good summer that's
what it was
a fifth grader would know you know where
the it's by the the
red tree with the this like you know and
then you gotta pass it down almost
like something like very tragic yeah you
gotta leave a map exactly
but there are some people who are like
goonies but i was
i was too young for that right so like
i'm 34. so the internet
like aol like the internet came out when
i was like in like third grade
i know i know see i i wasn't i don't
know i wouldn't do i think that
this next generation is never going to
know the struggle of of riding your bike
to the woods i didn't i'm saying i
i knew it we didn't have to do it though
like when i was in sixth grade i could
just
look up no i know and let me tell you
something i'm gonna
ruin a couple of computers i'm older
than both of you so i was in the thick
of that
it was [ __ ] better because there was
nothing
you would you would never more i don't
know it was the hormones or what it was
but like getting that yes it was an
accomplishment it was like oh
and that [ __ ] i've said it over and over
and over again i think that
like a mountainous eruption we're the
we're the greatest generation
because we well you've had it and
haven't had it yes we know like
that analog and digital lives i can walk
in both worlds
yes we're young enough to adapt like you
know you they walk
your iphone your parents and you're like
i can't figure out this thing so it's
like
you're worthless society you can't
contribute you can't have a job you
can't adapt
we can do that but i also know i
remember the life when i didn't have an
entire endless library of hd porn right
there on my fingertips
yeah i remember you know i would have to
go
because it would kind of keep the keep
it in frame you know somebody with the
spice channel
hearing that [ __ ] door open on aim
with the hot chick logs in
like
messages my grandma had a black box with
illegal cable
yeah sounds like a freak my grandmother
[Laughter]
she used to get her tent cigarettes
bootlegged off the indian
reservation and she had a black box
cable box and she would always yell
upstairs
you're not watching the dirty channels
are you and i'd be like
yes i am [ __ ] that's the price is
right again
grandma downstairs it was some weird
door oh
no yeah that's living on the edge yeah
and i hear the steps coming up and
do the waistband tuck and change the
channel yeah that's the irish idiot
you want the risk of getting caught yeah
it can also hide your dickies
[Laughter]
um we've touched on this and we've done
it but this is a new person uh
if we did it in the early the thing now
we're finally as the show gets we have
more episodes of [ __ ] that we've talked
about in the
beginning right everybody's missing yeah
yeah so this is from verena i think in
austria or switzerland she was from
shout out to uh you know
the europeans uh big fan of the show
last time i
i cooked my friend pointed out that
putting the eggshells back in the carton
is extremely trashy
yeah now that's what i do i did it today
so we do
i mean you eventually throw them out but
when the cartons are done oh
no i'll put it back in the fridge and
throw out a cart with twelve cracked
eggs it's deplorable deplorable yeah
yeah it's
trash in the moment when i'm cooking
making it i'll put it back
but then you know that eventually i know
that's what chefs do that's what chefs
do i know that first yeah but they're
back in the but they're not storing a
thing of
because they go through eggs that quite
fast yeah like they go through a part of
eggs and [ __ ] if you want to be
putting
cream it's bad it's okay because there's
also usually some
remnants of the yolk the yogurt sure
everything's stuck
in there but my head is going well it's
keeping it cold that's keeping it at
whatever temperature that's not going to
make
germs you know what else helps with the
germ situation throw it in i know
before you get them at the store will
you open the cart and look at them yeah
yeah i guess i should but
i'm not buying i'm not paying 12 for 12
eggs and getting 11.
eggs eggs are something the thing that
i'll buy
and then they'll just sit there a full
dozen until they go right oh really
i just i'll do these things right now i
get four today i go to the grocery store
and i buy like all the things that my
kids need to eat and like the snacks
that i like but every now and then i'll
go on a trip where it's like i gotta get
real food and i gotta get maybe one day
i'm gonna
bake something so i need that one i'm
going to need this and that and then
they you know everything i buy just
expires
yeah you ever get the uh you ever see
someone buying the 18 pack that's real
trash
i'll do that from time to time you get
the big boy why is that trashy the
cadillac baby the big body bench if you
need a lot of eggs you need a lot of
eggs
take it out first eggs yeah that's a
that's an old school
big body 80s ben love it sharp corners
yeah
that and the jumbos yeah that's all i do
i did i did regular i did just regular
large eggs today and i had to do four
because i felt like i'm like what are
these [ __ ] little
they're like they're like [ __ ]
birding dude that doesn't add up they're
not jumbo chickens where are they
getting these eggs
i don't ask i don't care how the sausage
is made daddy give me the big bowl give
me a t-rex egg
you just said what are these bird eggs
well i meant like you know like a
collection
like yeah like a tiny little [ __ ] let
me tell you something about that i don't
know who's making this decision at
grocery stores and it's even trickling
down to like acmes and like shitty ones
these [ __ ] quail eggs
get them the [ __ ] out of my egg section
i didn't even know there was quincy
you haven't seen quail eggs at the store
now they're everywhere you're shopping
the farmer's market
no i'm telling you i'm telling brooklyn
[ __ ] you know yeah they're [ __ ]
they're like but you know what it it is
funny to think about like
all of eggs is rather disgusting of
course i can't think of a person to be
like
well this is usually a chicken embryo
that will grow to be a chicken but if we
get to it a time and we fry
it we can like yeah that was one of his
first bits ever yeah yeah it's crazy
i think about that hey johnny do you see
that bird you [ __ ] that thing out yeah
let's eat it throw it in a frying pan
right that's absolutely don't you go
take a bite
i do that with all sorts like who was
the first person to to get a coffee bean
grind it up yeah put it in the water and
drip water
put it in a pla a paper thing and then
drink it drink milk
same [ __ ] yeah well we're the only
species that uh drinks another species
all
milk does the body good you looked at me
like you were trying to hypnotize me you
were like yeah
yeah just dropping some milk knowledge
on you or melting
or hershey's for me i don't give a [ __ ]
all right let's do a couple of more here
all right this is from ryan
uh do you or a family member have a
house where there's imprints on the wall
from where the doorknob smashes because
there's no stopper
do you have that in your current house
uh yep yeah 100
yeah that's a tough look just like the
the lock or whatever like the
it's just [ __ ] it's just a poorly
designed piece of architecture where
doors can hit it to other doors and
walls and yep we had numerous door
stoppers that went awry that were like
broken and
the dingers those are awesome
i would lay on the goddamn floor oh damn
grounded
[Laughter]
that's hypnotizing just trying to get
through solitary
those those things would [ __ ] up a gi
joe wait until i can hit the yard for an
hour
i was doing a three to five bid three to
five hours in my room at night spent an
hour doing the curtains up and down
i've done that [ __ ] play with the
blinds
i thought of one on the train the other
day and i want to say it before i forget
when you see a you uh an already
scratched
lotto ticket on the ground do you check
it to see if it's a winner
jesus do you not in a long time but i
have for sure jesus
christ see a cigarette butt on the floor
you pick it up and smile i could see
toby doing that back in the day when he
smoked sick
picking up a cigarette picking up a butt
off off the street he still got some on
it
when he was riding his skateboard i
definitely have thought about
the the lottery ticket for sure i think
about it probably every time i see it
but i
also know the jeans the makeup of a
person that
is playing scratch off lottery tickets
is not losing a scratch all it's not
losing
that's like their holy grail yeah
exactly so it's like it's discarded by a
garbage person because it's garbage yeah
that's that's
it's a one in a billion shot that they
misplaced a winner
you ever think about picking up a metro
card like maybe there's some still
swipes on there i've cut
when i was when i was really poor yeah
it's right in our first couple of years
it's just like i gotta do it again
yeah the first couple years up here
metro cards at any cost
how about that that's that's gone now
huh you can just you just zap it with
your phone
no but but then it just builds you yeah
i guess
no you don't need a car anymore that
omni thing you can just put your phone
up against it
yeah that's right i guess because that
was one thing is i always used to do
monthlies
or weeklies but now i don't take it
anymore i never had the courage to buy
it monthly
only a week or the for the operating
never had him you never capital maybe
you're gonna die tomorrow yeah waste the
money yeah
every week yeah i'm not i don't know the
responsibility of losing that dude he
was also used to i mean i haven't taken
the subway with you in a long time but
he was the king
of [ __ ] just putting one ride on the
card
and then like we'd be rushing to get to
a show or whatever and i could hear the
train coming so i'm like all right let's
go
over there and i got a weekly and he's
like hold on and he's like yelling at
the guy in the booth can you put 58
cents on this
and he's got like a handful of nickel
i'm like dude just [ __ ] come on
well that's we've got your [ __ ] i think
we've done before
i think one of the questions is filling
up gas right do you fill up the tank or
do you put in like you know ten dollars
at a time of course
of course the city version of that
what's your move
uh when i actually do fill up yeah i
feel i'm all filled i i think that one's
particularly stupid if you're there just
[ __ ] fill up
now when i i i will say when i was
breaking when i was in high school and i
didn't have money then
sure it's whatever yeah but if you know
now it's like you're gonna need the gas
the price is just [ __ ] the price of
the price just sure let me ask you this
is it garbage to think that the car runs
better with a full tank
as opposed to oh no i'm zipping when i
got a full tank i feel it it did
i think it's psychological but yeah it's
like this i feel
i feel more powerful when my phone's
fully charged yeah i feel like i feel
like higher faster you feel like a
million bucks
can't be goes airborne with what dude if
i got over 90
on the iphone i'm cooking that's
definitely a real thing my phone is low
i feel like sliding oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] i don't want to
go to the nurses that's a funny bit
that's a sketch
that's pretty good that's amazing uh
while we're on this this is from keith
uh do you lift and shake the gas pump
hose to get every last drop into the
tank i i don't
you'll do the guy i definitely give a
couple squeezes more
i can't tap it on the way out when
mine's when mine hits it it hits it
if i try to go anymore it [ __ ] goes
everywhere well yeah
yeah but that's what i mean well i guess
if you're putting in like 20.
if you're not that that would be like if
you're not filling it up right because
it's 20 stops when the tank is full but
if you're only yeah
i saw when i got gas the other day and
as i stepped up the
on the screen was like the last person
seven dollars
you gotta hope they were like filling up
a weed whacker or something you know
what i mean
you're hoping they were like listen i
gotta hold this guy
up a weed record right from the pump
though i meant in a gas can
yeah but i i i almost like i looked at
that and i went like
i'm thinking like whoever drove away
from here they've seen some things like
they're down and out i almost wish i
could pay it forward and find that guy
dude he's a 20 for the full thing i
would always do i would i remember that
i would do five bucks oh yeah let me get
five on pump too
you ever run out of gas uh no i've come
very close
who was that uh feidelberg i think was
asked this question recently
yeah we were talking about this i feel
like it was yeah i was kind of like no
i'm like i got a brain in final break
yeah i think he was he was like oh like
ten times
oh yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
that's not even necessarily uh garbage
that's
just you're an idiot it's just yeah [ __ ]
you i mean run out of gas
i don't have a license yeah i mean come
on he's our he's literally our 14 year
old child
are you a city guy like you you never
had need for a car he lives in
connecticut
how did you just raise it well or did
you drive you just want a license it's
like a whole thing i never
never never never needed one never
he went to boarding school in high
school feinlberg did that too i think
you go to a boarding school in high
school you end up being a [ __ ] wacko
haha no offense you're wacky you must
you got a table in place
what's this guy doing coming and calling
it exactly how it is [ __ ] look me in
the eyes
and make the exact right call his
[ __ ] [ __ ] in his sweatpants
you were trembling at him in the
beginning of the show i feel like when
you're you know when you're
that age younger you go to college it's
fine when you're like
living away from home uh at like you
know in eighth grade and that's [ __ ]
just weird
there was aspects that made it seem
appealing there were sure there was
a year-long summer camp you know yeah
there was movies that made it seem like
yeah this would be awesome
but i've never seen that sleep inside
and being like nah [ __ ] that yeah
but like cruel intentions
[Laughter]
sleep the sleepers those guys had a
tough tough go
yeah i'm not talking about being walked
out of the boiler room
same thing i always wanted to cut my ass
so watch you die talking about
this guy talking about going a dark
place i i do respect the uh the move
from parents being like someone else is
gonna do this
i'm outsourcing my my parenting you know
what i mean yeah someone else raised
these [ __ ] kids yeah it's almost like
being raised by your english teacher
isn't a good idea
who knew who would have thought i always
loved the movie my my cousins are jewish
and uh
you know they might they did the summer
camp thing where it was just like their
parents are sending you away for
for three months in the summer and my
parents uh three months ago the whole
thing
yeah yeah they sleep away camp that's
being interesting in july august our
squad's starting to do that now but
they're going for like
four weeks or five weeks oh yeah they
were doing the full summer and then my
aunt and uncle
would be down at their beach house in
long beach [ __ ] living it up swinging
key parties
the whole thing he's in the ball baby
yeah because we don't have our kids for
the next two and a half months
summer camp is pretty awesome though
yeah and then that's the thing the kids
loved it like i didn't really do it
either because
i really feel like that was like a
jewish thing but they were loving it the
parents were free and like this
makes sense yeah we only did it once
like my niece and nephew were doing it
now like proper like sleep away like you
know rich kid [ __ ]
that was always weird i always did like
like i went to fordham basketball camp i
did it
yeah stuff like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm gonna
live in like a cabin we're gonna shoot
[ __ ] bow and arrows yeah yeah
skip hearts and crabs like lady get me a
pack of bernies i'm gonna be stealing
wine coolers for my mom we did stones
they always got not laid but like i
remember the kids who would go to camp
always came back like i gotta hand you
oh you [ __ ]
got handsy way quicker [ __ ] yeah i know
a lot of the kids are also lying about
that but there's also the kids getting
jerked off in like sixth and seventh
grade and i was listening
remember that news i remember the first
time somebody touched a boob
yeah i found i got a phone call at home
on like a sunday night
yeah i was like jesus christ where i'm
on my way
kevin
[Laughter]
that's a weird period of time where
you're in like sixth seventh eighth
grade that middle school it's like
like one of my friends was like losing
his virginity and i was like i'm afraid
to talk to a girl yeah
yeah yeah i got a new girlfriend i was
like oh have you kissed her yet he was
like
yeah he sucked my dick last weekend oh
yeah me too totally totally bro i'm
getting my dick sucked also
just had a threesome what are you
talking about yeah transformers
backpacking
yeah hey hey hey timmy you want to come
over and sleep over there what do you
think about the
dick sucks i got anything anal tonight
like get out of here
all right that's that's it i got a wrap
wow that was quick
gang we love you very much uh thank you
for tuning in kfc anything you got for
me you want them to know other than
what they got uh just do uh uh ten
minutes ten topics is the new thing so
one minute man has been
you know thriving on instagram fantastic
trying to get uh into youtube a little
bit more so it's the same sort of idea
uh current events and headlines where i
try to break it down for you real quick
so
the 10 most important topics of the week
in 60 seconds or less each so that's on
the kevin clancy youtube and the kfc
radio youtube so
subscribe to both of those of course you
can listen anywhere else but we're
really working on the youtube
so subscribe uh to kc radio and the
kevin clancy show on youtube
we text you all the time about those the
one minute man so i know i guess all of
my news
i know i mean i can tell you guys always
are watching and they're not blowing
yeah
this reporting [ __ ] smart calculated
i [ __ ] love it yeah
make sure you check it out ken kippy
what do you got for him out there uh
just as always please make sure you rate
view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and then
patreon.com also i'm at cameron comedy
on all social media and follow the ru
garbage pages it's at are you garbage on
twitter and instagram and also dude
thank you so much
you've been such a [ __ ] supporter
it's uh it's so [ __ ] cool
i listened to that the most recent
episode i think of you guys you're
talking about the
the tour you did down in north carolina
north carolina
tennessee both you guys just talked
about how it's working and how you
finally made it and i'm sure it's been a
long road for both of you guys
thank you guys who deserve it more so
keep doing your thing i'm glad to help
appreciate it and we owe that all to you
guys we love you guys very much
and uh mentioning raleigh and nashville
come see us in [ __ ] ac
ac indianapolis and chicago are you
garbage
[ __ ] just the super bowl baby let's
go june 18th down there at the celebrity
theater
down there in atlantic city and then
indianapolis and [ __ ] chicago
it's [ __ ] gonna be a garbage summer
yeah baby we're popping
we love you guys we'll see you next week
peace